how bad marxism is how it makes everyone
poor what we forget is it makes a small
number of people really rich and that's
why they're in favor of patrice cullers
is a
marxist she's a co-founder of blm and
she's taken her newfound riches
shaking down corporations and bought a
couple big houses a number of them
but that's not all she's buying we're
learning a lot more about her spending
habits
fox's trace gallagher has that story for
us hey trace hey tucker patrice cullers
also founded a group called reform la
jails which last year successfully led a
ballot measure to reduce the jail
populations in los angeles county turns
out
in 2019 that jail reform group had quite
the gathering at a malibu beach resort
called
calamigo's guest ranch the group spent
more than 10 000
at the resort itself and 15 plus
thousand on a conference center owned by
the resort
we don't know why they gathered for this
oceanfront meeting because the daily
caller news foundation which broke the
story can't find public records of the
meeting
but critics say if everything is on the
up and up why did the jail reform group
book the beach club through a consulting
firm that just happens to be owned by
asha bandel
the woman who co-authored patrice
culler's 2018
biography asha bendel also raked in
nearly 260 thousand dollars
in consulting fees from you guessed it
reform
la jails it's unclear if the california
commission that regulates political
groups plans to look into this
but a conservative watchdog group
already
raising red flags tucker
trace gallagher thanks so much hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else